ladies and gentlemen Jane Fonda and Alan
Alda
good evening all 1 billion of you there
are so many people around the world
watching tonight that we're calling on
the linguistic services of our co-host
Robin Williams
the Academy sends greetings to the
People's Republic of China niihama
Yong Hwa rang hello to the people of
India an America's ambassador Namaskar
hello to the French salute ASEAN or
public falls special congratulations to
the people of the Philippines come on
down some of these shows have never been
worn
come on down come on down you'll get two
pairs of shoes one black cross three
come on down come on down no in New
Jersey one 800 in Switzerland I don't
know
come on down
Thank You Robin each and every one of
you well it's time for the Oscars again
yeah attentions to say nothing of
limousines have been stretched beyond
endurance another year another night
with the fervent hope that the night
doesn't take another year some of our
winners will clearly be at a loss for
words their search may go on
indefinitely yeah with that in mind we'd
like to say a little something to those
whose cups so runneth over that
sometimes the show runneth over as well
so you won't have to please let us thank
the following for you one or both of
your parents depending on how well they
got long and or which one got custody of
you your husband or your lover or all
three have you bled a color the life
your children who having been thanked
can now switch over and watch something
r-rated on cable your agents your
manager your lawyer your accountant your
therapist analyst publicist aerobics no
offense no you win whoever lent you a
hand
lent you an ear went you a dime your
director who became the soil that
allowed you to grow the people in makeup
and wardrobe and props here the acting
coach the coach driver he assistant
everyone the guard at the gate the
animal trainer the animals and the
writer why not and now in keeping with
another movie tradition we have a coming
attraction a presentation of all the
Academy Award nominees we're here to
honor tonight each a star in their field
together a dazzling constellation ladies
and gentlemen here is the class of 1986
we'll all the nominees please stand
and now a director producer whose films
have earned an amazing 61 nominations
winning 19 Oscars he himself has been
nominated seven times and won four
Academy Awards ladies and gentlemen the
president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences Robert Wise
music and many many others good evening
I'm sure some of you some of the very
nearly 1 billion viewers are wondering
about this August Academy of ours it
comes together once each year to give
out nude statuary what's the curriculum
at this Academy how does one get in do
they have a football team well to answer
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences is not a school there are no
professors in long robes giving
dissertations on the signs and symbols
of cinema Transylvania no our Academy is
a collective of the most accomplished
men and women who make motion pictures
actors directors writers musicians
editors the person who tells you how the
set should look the person who tells you
you can't afford to build that Center
our members call cities from Hollywood
to Budapest to Tokyo of their homes and
they run an age gamut from Justin Henry
up to whatever age George Burns is this
year we work together this Academy of
ours to share knowledge to preserve the
achievements of the past to celebrate
the achievements of the present and
nurture those who will create the
achievements of tomorrow in the most
far-reaching and powerful art form in
the planet the moving picture on behalf
of our worldwide membership
welcome to the Academy's 58th annual
award presentation ladies and gentlemen
and Richard Dreyfuss
thank you